بينما أطلقت عاصفة قوية ومميتة
العنان لفيضانات مدمرة في شرق
ليبيا، نقلت تقارير وسائل الإعلام الرسمية عن
مسؤول قوله إنه يخشى مقتل أكثر من 2000 شخص
في
مدينة واحدة، ولم يذكر المسؤول مصدرًا
لأعداده وقال الهلال الأحمر.  في
وقت سابق، قدروا أن ما بين 150 إلى 200 و50
شخصًا لقوا حتفهم في مدينة
درنة الآن بسبب الأمطار الغزيرة التي تغمر
كما ترون هذا المستشفى أيضًا مما أدى إلى
غمر الشوارع وانقطاع
خدمة الهاتف، وقد حصلت المنطقة على أكثر من
ثلثي هطول الأمطار السنوي المعتاد.
هذا في يوم واحد فقط جاء من
البقايا كما تتذكر كنت أتحدث
عن الأسبوع الماضي من العاصفة دانيال التي
ضربت اليونان الأسبوع الماضي أريد
إحضار بن ويديم الخاص بنا وينضم إلي الآن
للمزيد وبن هذا
مدمر تمامًا فقط أعط  لدينا إحساس بما
تسمعه من السلطات هذه
الساعة،
حسنًا، الشخص الذي قدم هذا الادعاء
هو رئيس الوزراء أسامة حمد وهو
رئيس وزراء
الحكومة الانفصالية لشرق ليبيا ومقرها
بنغازي، وقال إن هناك ما لا يقل عن
2000 شخص  لقوا حتفهم نتيجة
لهذه الفيضانات في مدينة درنة
بالإضافة إلى أنه يدعي أن ما
يصل إلى 5000 شخص قد يكونون في عداد المفقودين الآن لقد
زرت درنة إنها مدينة يبلغ عدد سكانها حوالي
مائة ألف شخص في الجزء السفلي
من  جبل الآن عبارة عن قاع نهر جاف،
يمر الوادي عبر دونا، ولكن يبدو أنه
نتيجة لكمية الأمطار التي
هطلت على دانييل، سقطت في تلك المنطقة، كما
قلت، فقد اجتاح ثلثي
هطول الأمطار السنوي في يوم واحد فقط.
وسط تلك المدينة
وما نراه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يبدو أنه يذكرنا بما
يحدث في المغرب الآن من حيث
حجم الدمار الآن
ليس من الواضح تماما ما هو مصدر
هذا الادعاء الذي لا يقل عن ألفين  قتيل
وخمسة آلاف مفقود أه رئيس الوزراء
حمد لم يذكر أه
هذا المصدر ولكن من الواضح أن هناك
أضرار جسيمة في درنة وربما
خسائر فادحة في الأرواح وكذلك
قلت جمعية الهلال الأحمر الليبي
ربما تقول الكثير  مثل 250 قتيلاً،
ولكن بمجرد النظر إلى تلك الصور
يشك المرء في أن
عدد القتلى ربما يكون أعلى بكثير، نعم
بالتأكيد هذه الصور تبدو
كارثية للغاية عندما ننظر إلى بعض
الصور التي حصلنا عليها بين عشية وضحاها فيما
يتعلق بما قاله رئيس الوزراء  قال الوزير هل هو
طلب المساعدة الدولية هل
هو طلب المساعدة من الآخرين
لأن هذه الصور حقا أه حقا
صادمة أه نعم
الليبيون
يطلبون المساعدة بشدة أه في الحقيقة رئيس
الإمارات زيد قال ذلك  سوف
يرسلون مساعدة عاجلة
على الفور والأمم المتحدة تطلب المساعدة
أه وكذلك قلت ليس من الواضح
تمامًا مدى
الضرر وعدد القتلى وعدد
المفقودين ولكن من الواضح أن هناك
حاجة ماسة للمساعدة و  الليبيون يطلبون
أه ذلك على الفور قال نحث على
الحاجة إلى المساعدة الإغاثية بشكل واضح بن
فيدمان لنا هناك شكرا جزيلا
بن